you have to be sensitive
in addressing the most uncomfortable
topics way before you hire them
number one like i said do you want a
salary or do you want to be a consultant
i don't want to be a consultant then if
your salary you have to report i'm good
with that then if you report there's
accountability i'm good with that
so but that can't be like oh my gosh
we're going to take over the world
together let's go
oh [ __ ] we're fighting we're having
problems no no no no no like
slow down and take a few more weeks
before you do this but ask all the
difficult questions
and sora and it's it's the closest thing
to a prenuptial agreement you can have
and i don't know if you have a nuptial
agreement or not i'm all about nuptial
agreements
it's the closest thing to a nuptial
agreement you can have and i'm i'm 100
fan of nuptial agreements i recommend it
to every man i know that has money and
then his incentive the way it's set up
you got to comp
the salary benefits all the other stuff
you negotiate then it's
you know 20 bonus 25 bonus whatever the
bonus
will be based on markers what are
markers if he hires this person for me
if he raises this much money if the
ebitda is around this number if we grow
at a 40
rate whatever if we if we if we if we if
we whatever those markers are going to
be
then he knows what he has to hit if he
doesn't hit it he doesn't get that 25
bonus so if you pay him a salary of i
don't know pick a number
uh uh for the sake of easy math let's
just use a hundred thousand dollars
obviously you have to pay more than 100
the sake of that if you use a hundred
thousand dollars and you say i'm gonna
pay an additional fifty percent of
bonuses great
divide it amongst five different uh
areas ten percent
if the company grows by forty percent
net profit so we're doing a million
dollars this year
if we grow and do 1.4 million you hit
your 10
000 bonus great next i need a ceo i need
a director of finance and i need a
controller
if you find those three that's another
ten thousand dollars great
three i need to expand into two new
markets and if you help us grow
expansion
great boom i need the office to be
restructured set up and you know blah
blah blah
police everything bathrooms okay great
so you create whatever those markers are
with the incentives
he's got his date today plus those five
incentives that gives them the
additional 25
bonus and inequity will be based on
investing period he's gonna want three
years you're gonna want five years
you'll settle on four years he may agree
to five years you may have to agree
on three years because this guy's just
better than you and you're gonna have to
work together on relationship
you know calling him out you can't
undermine him
you know you can't talk to him like a
boss see somebody that's self-made but
behind closed doors if you can
how's the accountability going to work
out all of that matters so you just got
a sneak little peek from an episode that
i did in this video if you want to see
the full episode click over here to
watch the entire episode and if you've
not subscribed
to this channel please do so take care
everybody